sir what's going on Chloe I wasn't sir
no I just went I just went I know the
other girl I know the roommate but I
know the one who lives there you know
what mean so I went up there I was like
I was going to for light I was going to
get Li but she didn't have one hey yeah
so listen we've been getting a lot of
calls on you just now yeah one of the
calls I guess you were chasing after
somebody with the bat no that was
another girl she was chasing me with the
bat she was chasing you with the B for
no reason and then there was a call just
now that you were trying to get into
somebody's house
no sir no sir no what uped in your
face why are you bleeding you have blood
all over you really yeah look at your
arm your left arm oh she was tracing
with the back I don't know you get hit
yeah no not
really
okay dude they rested they were in my
homeless for no reason last night you
know you want to go
see yeah what it is that
uh as far asag up this way yeah they
were pointing at us it's going to be
that house right there you want me to go
talk to him oh you want me to go talk to
him all right I stay with her
then how's it going did you guys call
she did she's the one of the house who
did I guess her we didn't we kicked her
out of that house you guys kic her out
of this house she was trying to break
into our neighbor's house we're the ones
that went over and told her to out where
did you guys see when she was over there
uh she was on top of the the pork right
there she was trying to open the door
okay and then we went over there cuz I
mean they're girls hey what are you
doing keep walking what are you doing
there and that's when she she thought
she was getting she backed up her going
wait up let's Ki her out of here cuz she
was just there just sitting there just
trying to open the door was she kicking
the door or just no just jiggling the
door just trying to get in there she's
whacked out of her mind yeah yeah yeah I
mean but still luckily we were out here
you know she was doing her thing and
she's like hey Bae bae what's up and he
came out I was in the restroom then I
came out I was like oh shit let's go now
I'll go talk to her right now okay thank
you you're welcome bud are you the one
that called us I am yes so what happened
um I was pulling up um I came home and
there was this lady on my porch and they
were talking to her trying to get her
off and they said that she tried to get
into the house she took up after that so
you said you saw her on your property
yes sir okay there people inside no when
she was trying to open no
okay all right if I need anything else
I'll give you a call thank you so we'll
get for public for being in the street a
couple times a day then this there wants
to take
it Chloe what do me a favor wa can tell
me wait back up back up first sir relax
sir sir wait guys stop relax walk back
up sir sir stop ow sir I'm asking you
stop I didn't do anything sir stop hey
turn around Hey sir brother hey stop
don't brother stop I didn't do anything
stop
sir are you talking about bro no tell
him to stop relax that's the
problem oh my God I don't want to get
arrested that's the problem
I'll take your
Dum don't attack me like a no don't take
don't
take stop relax like what
WR why you
I I I
wasn't no sir y that was last night that
was last night that's a lie that was
last
night that was last night
Sir no it doesn't help bro like how you
like switch sides like that Rel like
you're little kid bro St don't start
acting like you're like some
B we're trying
to you're under arrest Chloe like you're
so stupid
you're
retard how hard is
it I didn't I will have a blue team and
[Music]
[Applause]
a AC aggressive you guys are stupid
stand for will CA
take me to another jail a whole
different jail you
retards like what are you what do you
guys do
huh let go bro bro don't let don't let
them bro wait wait I wait wait you're
going to hurt me don't hurt me don't
hurt
me no relax stand up or I'm going to get
a wheelchair if you don't walk stand up
bro I can't do
[Applause]
this oh God
you I didn't R nobody
bro 3
please don't R you down like I get it I
know
like so J down that's I try to tell you
they're
done going to will you in right tell him
to stop okay we'll tell him watch your
feet don't drag your feet
try you're to fall like stop here it go
you're
right like
go hard time me too bro now you huh are
you hurting anywhere yeah I'm hurt where
yeah I'm hurt where taking for everybody
what about brand bro what not Jesus this
is why for no F
reason I'm
sorry okay you guys run
around
can I use your ear to take your
temperature
I
I know mean to Fu bro I'm tired of relax
I'm done bro just need to take your time
I'm done I don't need to go to jail
you're going to jail you're already sir
sir please and you yelling isn't help no
I there's there is things going on I
have been talking to the president I
have been
Treasurer I don't want to I don't have a
reason to go to jail guys Chloe we're
going so sir sir please I'm begging you
guys please Rel sir please I really
don't want to go I have no reason I have
no reason I literally didn't do anything
though turn around sir I don't want
please I have another charge and I
didn't do anything if you keep resisting
you're going to get another charge sir
please please don't charge me sir okay
well then calm down